hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cuphead I'm calmed
down a bit I don't know why I was mad in
the first place but let's go into the
third mausoleum and see if we can get
our last super I don't know my slappa
skills may need some work well these
guys are getting kind of antsy about
this sighs went silent as I was trying
to concentrate there I don't know why
it's not gonna make anything different
my skills are exactly as they were whoa
you are weird I don't like what the hell
what can I know that was too close
oh god this slap of [ __ ] think that
they can be me I see up shits all right
that's right
No oh no it was right there with the
slapper [ __ ] god damn it I had that in
the bag I don't know why I could add it
first try but no I got a big stupid God
then why'd that happen
nope oh god damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn damn damn damn damn damn damn
damn it damn it
huh these guys are really good Nancy
Nancy in my pants II all right but I'm
getting the best of them are you big
slap a [ __ ] Oh give me the magic baby I
don't know how good the invulnerability
is gonna do me but thank goodness you
came by I was a stupid idiot and went
into another mausoleum and got tray up a
door again here's the last magical super
art I was able to find for you well time
for me to take a powder good look All
Right see ya see ya baby
ghost lady all right I love you you
little sand guy mom dad I guess all
right unlock the new super hey let's see
what that one's about John goes maneuver
your spirit and body simultaneously for
maximum damage alright you know what
I'll give it a try I don't know what
that means but I'll do it I suppose but
the shop hello for crane Thanks about
this one
whatever that means this whoa coffee
super media meter continuously fills in
addition to what you earned oh that's a
be like that what's sown your first
berry moves doubles as a damaging hoe
that's a handy dandy thing I'm a big
okay all right well that's something to
look forward to hey as gone for Key
North everyone ends a grade A rating if
you know what I mean and not everyone
can maintain that level of quality over
time consistency my dear friends that is
what it's all about then you will
experience the scintillating sensations
that I do all right
I don't know what that means but
whatever okay thanks for being a kind of
a douche I guess marine corpse whatever
just so long as I can use my precision
strike on you oh oh that seems bad whoa
okay I see what's going on there this
ain't so bad whoa okay that's pretty bad
with the exploding there that zoth was
easy as ein zwei drei oh one two three
why do you guys have to be German so I
gotta watch out for not only the bombs
but thereafter blows no I ran right into
that one that was my bad why is there a
wait what was that outside outside oh
come on give me my goddamn super I slap
is in need of more slappa slappa nappa
whoa god damn it what did I just do oh
hey how's it going well this is weird
okay
well that's strange okay I'm dead I
didn't know that was gonna happen okay
all right then well that's no good I got
it I got a guy
okay I don't know if this does but here
we go whoa okay well that's Oh what the
heck is what why didn't know how that
worked I I was just I don't know what
happened but to be perfectly honest I
have no idea okay that's weird okay this
is this bizarre hey let me get a good
shot of ya no not jump oh there's a
second level oh that's handy oh that
ain't good oh that ain't good either
okay the fire yeah okay the fire the
fire the fire okay I should switch to my
other weapon to that stage come on why
are there so many butt plugs on the back
shelf over there by the way come on come
on come on come on you cherry bomb blast
and bastard you thinking me huh again I
don't know what this is gonna do but I'm
gonna try all right here we go this
thing apparently
wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb
wobb wobb wobb out sack of [ __ ] ah well
the fire also is a thing that is a thing
okay but it it seems like that thing did
a lot of damage it did a lot of damage
all right I'm gonna mess up your butt
plug collection Pro broham you think
your butt plugs are safe for me nan sir
is no okay yeah see you're out of here
you're at this stage of desperation yeah
I see how it is
ba ba ba ba ba okay get that get that
yeah that's the stuff okay I see I see
what's going on here okay okay okay okay
Oh Oh haha dodged your [ __ ] all right
that's not good okay okay okay okay
there we go there we go got him got him
whoa whoa way that's that's awful that's
okay you know wow wow wow wow wow wow
wow you all right
that's awful that's horrible that's no
good I don't want to slap on that yeah I
don't want to slap anything about that
ghosty ghosty now when I sign up for
Oh baby okay Jesus ah what is that what
my heart I want to slap her that house
[ __ ] I shouldn't have slap at that oh
boy oh boy oh boy
what the hell no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no and about that
oh Jesus
how close was I god damn it god
okay go go go go get him get him
hit em hard here tomorrow noon tomorrow
hit him real hard yeah that's the good
stuff
oh that's the good stuff right there I
don't even know it's coming out oh [ __ ]
why I was dry I don't know what I'm
doing I don't know what I'm doing I
don't know Oh Frick come on really
really oh come on
goddamn it I did I didn't switch my
other weapon is my problem there okay
watch this is gonna be the one I got
this anybody who doubts me is down the
wrong horse you got to place your bets
now there's gonna be the one if there
was a way a betting system on YouTube
you have our stock betting right now
you're ready for your loot boxes of 12
who lost their bet then who won their
bet I bet yeah yeah okay yep here we go
unleash the beast within unleash well
that's okay there we are there we are
there we are there we are okay switching
weapon no fire I for almost forgot about
the fire that very important fire thing
but the fire is the only thing that I
need to remember in this entire endeavor
is literally the only thing that I need
to remember is the fire everything else
is just super easy oh no oh no oh no oh
no
here we go oh no he lost control oh
that's so sad I guess oh well he's very
dead all right cat you can't bastard you
think you messed with me
ah nan sir is no the case it wasn't
clear oh really the tiles are gonna
start on that end I slap I slap up I
slap I slappa I slap up I slap it no
register my slap off this guy is not
that art I do not know why I'm having so
much trouble with him
he's really not that hard this is
actually quite simple and yet I'm just
being a stupid that's all I'm really
doing I'm just being stupid you know you
guys know how I like been stupid and all
that that's me right now oh babe oh babe
mmm there we go that's the good stuff
that's the goods welp there he goes I
guess that's not the good stuff anymore
oh boy whoa God again with the stupid
thing the fire the only thing I need to
remember this entire match the only
thing the only thing I need to remember
is the fire it's the only thing say it
with me the only thing I need to
remember is you do fire do fire if that
was me being stupid okay this is the one
you know why cuz I got a dad a slap-up
and that's our up Dodger dad a slapper
to that also an option if me really am
think about it real hard that's fast you
know why cuz I'm so good ah okay the
fire it's the only thing I need to
remember the only thing I need to
remember is it the fire the fire is the
only thing I need to remember oh oh the
fire only thing I need to remember the
fire like I he was dead and I just
jumped into that for no reason there was
no reason I should have done that
absolutely no reason well that's awful
again that's very awful now boy
nah really really really really how
about you get some of this ghosts power
baby
[Music]
okay okay okay okay okay
ah I'm so this guy is not that hard
it is not hard okay all right okay I got
this I got this
the only thing that I need to worry
about is the fire which I just almost
got hit by because I was trying to dodge
something else but again not that big a
deal in the face of certain dumb like
that not that big a deal
cuz I got this on lock I'm watching out
for tiles and ghost poop the pink ghosty
puppy ain't gonna do nothin cuz I have
got an eye for quality slapper and
Agusta go star with the horse to Moscow
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay got hit by that
but that was not a fly if I get hit
again I'm gonna be so mad if I get hit
again I'm gonna be so mad if I come to
this last phase I get hit too stupid
times because I'm dumb that don't throw
it don't do it okay see you know I saw
you on the ground
I saw you on the ground slap up no this
is not that art I don't get why I'm
having so much trouble with this dock
and cover and duck yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah be scared be scared you be scared
I'm not scared because I'm the real
hunter here you gonna get blamed many
times look at lady if you are that thing
slap intensify god I slap with that I
did I did I did I did
I swear I slap at that it's just no [ __ ]
ah it's just me trying to slap a things
that's the only thing it's just me
trying to get a slap up I don't need it
I don't need it
why am I going for it the fire is the
only thing that I need to worry about
that's not good but I can survive it I
know what I'm doing because I'm smart
and full of poop I have to poop
did I mention I have to poop okay see
this is easy I don't know why I was even
trying with the other cannon before
because it's not necessary there we go
that's a slap-up if ever I saw seems bad
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine we're
fine we're fine what what was that what
was that what the hell oh come on
why why why I just lose focus for like a
second bam bam get dead just died
already just died yes [ __ ] you get out
of there oh you lying piece of [ __ ]
oh using the ghosts of your family to
fuel your stupid ambitions [ __ ] you you
weren't that hard I still maintain it
was not that difficult I had that in the
bag not my fault I also had the wrong
weapon for it should add like the spread
can and that would have been great for
it whatever gotten a - that's all that
matters
brick so anyway that's all the time I
got for this episode I don't know why
that took so long but I got it so thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think of this and thank
you everybody for being there with me
let me know if you want to see more cup
bad bomb probably are we gonna do it so
I love this so much Werner warming so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]